a common sight for these coronavirus
times
people pouring off public transport
wearing
face masks looking for that first gulp
of fresh air
masks in many places are compulsory
but as the weather gets warmer is that
enough to ease worries
i feel if i have a mask on my children
and i try to
make sure that i'm like one and a half
or two meters away from somebody who
also has masks
i feel quite sure obviously you can't be
too safe but
if you want to get it around this is
what you have to do
most modern trams and buses are fitted
with air conditioning units
which draw fresh air from the outside
but go underground and it's a slightly
different story
though passenger numbers are still down
compared to before the pandemic
carriages are starting to fill up again
unlike trams and buses most underground
systems around the world don't have air
conditioning
and so in confined spaces without much
ventilation
these are considered higher risk
despite the lack of air conditioning
transport officials point to other
sources of airflow
they use a lot of outside air to
ventilate the vehicles the whole time
that they're going and they're driving
then of course at the stations the doors
open up so you have ventilation there
the stations itself are ventilated by
the trains going back and forth because
you have these huge trains
pushing in with a speed moving out the
air
a coronavirus outbreak at a meat plant
in northern germany has put
air conditioning under the spotlight
again
it follows a chinese study that
suggested air conditioning helped spread
the virus to diners in a guangzhou
restaurant
if the air conditioner has a movement of
the air
they can transfer
the the droplets of the viruses
from one to the another therefore you
need
much more air fresh air from the outside
in such cases
scientists admit it's too early to make
any firm conclusions about
air conditioning units as well as fresh
air they say
high efficiency filters can help reduce
the presence of the virus
such filters are what airlines use
inside their cabins
recycling the airflow every three or
four minutes
but this only kicks in during the flight
and not
before and after these air conditions
has to be active before the passion
passengers
entered the plane we think that
air dry air promotes uh formation of
aerosols
and consequently the possibility of an
infection
as summer and the holiday season
approaches this year
there's more than simply just the
destination to consider